こんにちははじめ社長です
動画のタイトルにもございますか
視聴者の皆様に
このようなお願いをしてしまうこと
大変貌数件なく思っております
今回皆様に
お願いしたいことは
一つ
[音楽]
すいません3年前ほどでしょうか
初めてするの
肇社長の動画の
エンディング
皆様に
募集をかけたところ
[音楽]
大勢なムードがあって面白い
ピッキング
すごいいんでぃんぐ
楽しいビンディング
意味不明なウェディング
10秒あればできるようなエンディング
たくさんありましたがその中で一つ肇社長の動画のリングのして作業させて頂いたもの
が今のエンディングとなっておりま
音楽8ビットの2分シャツをすべてにおいてインパクトがある
素晴らしいエンディングを
3年間
使用させていただいたんですん
3月をもちましてん
字らしいエンディングにすべく
エンディング募集もう行ってしようと思いまー
はいそのままですハイあのエンディング発表会とかめちゃくちゃ盛り上がったんですよ
その山容されなかってエンディングをみんなで見るというレンディングの発表会とかも
全然後編めちゃくちゃ人気ですごい沢山の方が遅いといっていただいて本当にあの見て
いることが楽しかったですというわけで第1回
もう3年も使ってるんでしょこのエンディング月日葉茶
3年も使っているということでその人の快適じゃないかということで再び
募集させていただきたいと思います強いで応募方法なんですけども動画の概要欄
動画概要欄に棒5本目がございますのでそちらから応募ください
詳しい方法も全部こちらに書いてありますそして応募期間なんですけども
今日から3月の20日の15時
3月の下旬事物のジュンコ氏まで応募お待ちしておりますあとです著作権とかを
ちゃんと守っていただけると幸いです
音楽画像ボクっぽいイラスト特価キャラクターとか全然書いていただいて結構なんです
けども音楽は画像の社だけ宿に登りましょう
いうことを利用してくださいはいそしてですねあと僕の求めるエンディングゾーンなん
ですけど
そうですねぇ
とりあえずねなんかインパクトだと思うんですよねうん音楽映像すべてにおいて
インパクト後格好いうことが構えたとかお越しの方も含んだと思うんですけども
正直よく分かりますぜっ実際での見てみないとどれがしっくりくるなとかわかんないっ
て
ぜひ動画を作る技術のある方の素晴らしいインパクトのあるエンディングをお待ちして
おります申し訳ないんですけども面白すぎたり高すぎ払っちゃうレンディングは
ちょっと採用されないんですけどもエンディングの発表会とに使用される可能性はあり
ますのでそういうこともいいで是非お待ちしておりますあの wii とは言わないん
で本当に時間のある方だけで結構です参加
ずいろいろあると思うのでなかなか外出がしたくてもできない方とかいると思うんで
ぜひ見つけてみてください
てが空にっていうか低いのはちょっと厳しいかもですすいませ動画の a ティングと
いうことでクオリティは重視させていただきますすみませんよろしくお願いします
申し上げます本当にすいません
さていうことでサティもう兼任発表会でぜひ使わせていただきたいと思っておりますの
でそちらもぜひ皆さん
恐ろし僕も嬉しいみたい
皆さんも楽しい作っている方も時どっち
的な動画だと応用雪花という意味で皆さんのエンディング
お待ちしておりますじゃーん
me
ええええええ
あっはっ